chers amis bonjour jeu il me revient
d'animer la première table ronde je suis
obligé de poster je suis maire du xviie
arrondissement de paris mais je ne vous
parlerai pas en tant qu'élu parisienne
je laisserais ce plaisir à philippe
goujon tout à leur député de paris
président de la fédération aujourd'hui
dans cette première table ronde je
m'exprime aussi également en tant que
secrétaire national à la sécurité en
binôme avec bruno beschizza qui
justement va intervenir dans cette
première table ronde donc qui sera
consacré aux missions des forces de
l'ordre et je vais vous proposer trois
pistes de réflexion sur cette première
table ronde
la première c'est le rétablissement de
la reconnaissance des forces de l'ordre
et la redéfinition de leur mission avec
donc bruno beschizza qui apportera son
témoignage également en tant que mère de
l'aîné et en tant qu ancien policier
syndicaliste
le deuxième thème de réflexion ce sera
la clarification du rôle des polices
municipales et celui du maire avec
bernard reynès député secrétaire
national à la prévention de la
délinquance et on verra là aussi qu'il y
a un rapport entre les sujets que nous
étudions aujourd'hui et toute la
politique par ailleurs pénale caroline
ne pose menti et sportif qui est
adjointe au maire de marseille délégué à
la sécurité publique à la prévention de
la délinquance et enfin alexandre
vincent des gènes maire de rillieux la
pape
donc des profils vous l'avez compris
variés qui forts de leur expérience vont
nous faire part de leurs témoignages et
de leurs propositions
enfin troisième piste de réflexion la
sécurité privée n'est elle pas amené à a
développé ses missions avec un exemple
les opérateurs de service public que ce
soit les autoroutes la sncf la ratp ne
pourrait-il pas faire justement appel à
eux plutôt qu'aux forces de l'ordre pour
en discuter nous aurons christian
estrosi député maire de nice pierre bras
jeu qui est donc pdg de toran france ou
torrent toran toran qui est une société
donc de sécurité privée qui a été créée
en 1987 et qui je crois se positionne
dans les dix premières entreprises de ce
secteur alors premier point je le disais
à l'instant le rétablissement de la
reconnaissance des forces de l'ordre est
là
définition de leurs missions c'est en
effet au coeur de notre projet nicolas
sarkozy vous l'avez peut-être déjà lu ou
entendu ce matin sur les ondes en a fait
en un point important de ses
propositions en matière de sécurité nous
apparaît en effet vous l'avez compris
indispensable de recentrer les forces de
police et de gendarmerie sur leur corps
de métier à savoir l'ordre public
l'investigation la lutte contre la
criminalité et le renseignement je vais
donc laisser à bruno beschizza
développer nos propositions